unity is not something like substitute
of strategy but unity for sure if the
first and the main condition to do
anything shall you stay the course
to quote president tusk of value based
foreign policy shall we be faithful to
our principle more sanctions for more
war we are giving a chance to diplomacy
beta Oh Susanna do like this or Teja
come captive war zone is an event like
mine the Jonker you're on record saying
that there can be no democratic choice
against the European Union's treaties
that tells us all we really need to know
those really I think we are taking the
energy security issue to the high level
never before
you probably heard such ambitious
language cannot design that's via when
we are at five thousand films in an
energy onion and strategy food it
Zukunft and Chardon investment legend
does felling on Vashon the guinong's
theta at snow and soo comforts technolog
in in infancy Guyana three homogeneous
term autonomous and upon the zonda of
the Dadaist Mia Hamm in under an
institute soon real messy study era
history reservation Parliament's having
in the Commission's stodgy raffles
Bakersfield cabinets as a guinness
become seen so ants for the soul page
Parliament each cloud am insulted us in
undies and hiatus Commission's president
the mistress wine